panelists so you'll be able to
uh
address comments and questions
I would like to point out that you can
put your questions into the Q a box and
in fact I will do that in just a second
here we're starting our webinar now
we're going to talk about your fastest
route into a career in artificial
intelligence and machine learning
through the Caltech AIML boot camp
um please do put your questions into the
Q a box the session is being recorded
and we'll send a follow-up email with a
link to the recording and information on
a bonus offer you can claim for having
been at the session
and if you want to request a proof of
attendance for attending this webinar uh
you can do so yeah post webinar survey
so
let's start off with a quick question
for our audience how many years of
experience do you have and I'm putting
this into the
whole widget here so you can answer in
the poll
and I'll just leave this open for about
uh
15 more seconds
we're curious to know who's
in the audience today
and I'll close the poll in three
two one
machine we read a very um
our audience today is heavily weighted
toward people with more than five years
of experience
which is uh
really good we'll talk about how this is
a great program for those people and it
also applies to people who have less
experience yes
that's correct
so as we
go on I'm going to talk about
you of course we have poll questions as
you've seen we'll have a few more of
those uh Amit and I are going to discuss
with you Ai and ml careers
what the potential is for this field why
we think it's a great place for you to
build a career that's sustainable and
then we'll talk about the Caltech boot
camp what it offers you how it can help
you get into this field we'll share with
you some learner outcomes
I will share with you also how to get
enrolled and that bonus offer that I
mentioned
and finally we'll do a live q a where
you'll be able to get some questions
answered with the meet
um
I mean the
simply learn I'm going to introduce as
the world's number one online boot camp
we have been doing this for over 13
years and have helped 5 million
professionals around the world and 150
countries
to upskill in the digital domain
digital skills for the digital economy
we deliver all our programs online so
they are accessible to you anywhere that
you have a browser and a device so
um we're very proud that we're able to
help people in that way
we're very proud that we're affiliated
with instructors like I'm a teacher
um I mean I'm a teen could you please
give the audience a little bit of
background about yourself
and
your
history in this industry how you got to
the place you are
your thanks uh Stuart and hello everyone
uh thrilled to be uh here on this
webinar uh let me just share a bit about
myself and what brings me here I'm a
stats graduate I did my mbn it and I'm
incredibly passionate about analytics
and statistical concepts with over 16
years of experience in analytics product
development and training delivery in the
corporate world I have had the privilege
of working with diverse clients and
industries now throughout my career I
have had the opportunity to train more
than uh 4 500 hours in data science Ai
and ml tools and techniques for various
or corporate organizations and
additionally I feel honored to be
trainer for the prestigious institution
like Caltech and Purdue University as
well in association with simply learn
and in terms of skill set uh I have my
articles that spans a wide range of
areas including statistical modeling
natural language processing python
machine learning computer vision deep
learning so that's in a nutshell what
what my background is and started my
career as a data analyst and now I work
as a data scientist for my own company
which I run and I run a company since
last 10 years which creates a data
driven solution which primarily leverage
ML and AI Concepts so that's what that's
what I do thank you
that's a great illustration of how you
can develop
a career in Ai and machine learning
moving from the the domain of data
analytics into data science and then
into the
Advanced principles let me ask a
question of our audience
going to turn this on to um
what you see everyone else's answers as
well
um what is it that you think of when you
hear the term artificial intelligence
and machine learning what do you
what do you what is your impression of
that
let us know in the chat
you're out there in the audience because
uh tell us Skynet
first response is Skynet that's great
I'm also subset about it okay so some
interesting answers basic logic and
function for a given task
learner get left behind
uh future but actually it's more of the
present as as Paul says
neural network systems automation
not as smart as the human
right I have reduction in force okay
um
so these are all interesting Impressions
and let me uh
switch the chat back over but
I'm a team you've seen some of these
answers and
a couple of them talk about fear which
is the fear of the machines taking over
like Skynet in The Terminator movies or
um
replacing us
taking all our jobs away but um
abilities and just to add in this kind
of path actually itself I was reading
about James Cameron he mentioned he has
warned people in 1984 itself but books
apart uh uh Ai and machine learning if
you ask my view I look at it how uh
people have adopted to computers two
decades back three decades back I would
say like when it was introduced people
were very uh they were apprehensive
about it thinking that lot of jobs will
be lost but look at it where we have
gone to now computers have created a
huge Market a huge job opportunities and
and it has actually paved the part for
for machine learning and AI as well so I
strongly agree with the statement you
have mentioned in this slide that it
extends our human capability it will
help us in in in bringing uh the best
out of
ourselves in terms of solving a
particular problem I look at it as a
helping hand and that's how it will grow
also yeah and you correctly uh spoke
about you know technology throughout
history is for example
um
in the last century the century before
last in the 1800s uh in the United
States uh started that Century with
about 50 percent of population involved
in farming
um right now the the number is under
three percent
and that means that
everyone else is free to do other kinds
of productive work while those three
percent of the population can feed us
all
which is you know an amazing change and
and the Advent of computers has created
entire industries that no one had
conceived of outside of Science Fiction
before them so we're looking at a world
changing with AI and ml certainly but
changing in ways that maybe we can't
predict and in ways that we will adapt
to so the importance of of AI and ml in
business and the reason it's a great
career opportunity now is that
you know we're flooded with data
especially since the the pandemic
have you seen
the digital transformation change our
lives both before and during and since
the pandemic
and I would say uh uh if I start with
the during pandemic what happened uh we
took a pause and started understanding
that what's happening around us as a as
an organization and they started dealing
with uh a lot to be done with the data
that we are capturing and that was a
point where where actually we stopped
everything and started thinking how what
will be the path forward so probably in
a way it has given us understanding that
how we can optimize different processes
for any kind of business that we have
even for those businesses which we never
thought data will be a pretty important
uh element in terms of uh doing their
their day-to-day job so if you see
before uh pandemic uh
if I talk about the restaurant probably
they were never thought they will
utilize data in their processes they
were doing for the capturing their
clients probably getting more plans so
probably advertising and all but even
their processes could become better to
give an example so pandemic if you look
at from that perspective it actually
gave a lot of ideas and post pandemic we
started working on those ideas and
that's where a lot of automation we
started doing and then we started
thinking that probably Ai and ml can
manage a huge amount of data that we are
capturing and can help us in terms of
making decision faster because it works
in an automated fashion so that's how I
look at it if you ask me
thank you
um yeah and and to your point the the
ability to handle all of this data that
people didn't anticipate having to deal
with
um is is very important
not something that people can do with
paper and pencil it's not even something
people can do with vast arrays of
desktop computers or even data centers
at this point you have to
augment the data centers with
the capability the software and the
decision making capability to take in
all of that data and find patterns
within it that have meaning to business
so
um that's a way in which AI will help us
navigate this changing world and then
once you have the ability to to find
those patterns that are meaningful
um we're now in the in the world of
generative AI where the AI can
make suggestions to us about how to use
those patterns in a way whether that's
uh creating images or whether that's
creating text based on
you know the patterns that it sees so
this is a really interesting time in
history yes
that's correct and generative AI for
that particular matter is uh is this
growing like anything every now and then
we heard we hear that something new has
come up it started with a simple
probably image generation inventor
videos we are talking about text Data if
it has a huge potential and genetic AI
itself has become an entire field of
study which is quite exciting and and we
are hoping that it will actually give
some more uh uh a path breaking
applications let's see how it goes
so there's a number of different roles
and this is just a sampling of the kinds
of things that people can do in this
field and you talked about uh beginning
as a data analyst and moving into the
domain of data scientists with expertise
and uh
applications in artificial intelligence
and machine learning so can you comment
on some of these different roles and how
people can move laterally vertically
within them sure so so if I start with
the with the machine learning engineer
the idea here is how the job role will
will comprise of working with uh data in
terms of building machine learning
algorithm so entire machine learning
Project Life Cycle you'll have to manage
you'll not need to understand how you
need to push data into model and then
how to take care of the entire Model
cycle which is there which eventually is
basically solving a particular problem
so might be I'm building a model which
can identify if a transaction is
fraudulent or not so as a machine
learning engineer I'll be focusing upon
which machine learning algorithm
probably my work on this data that we
are talking about what kind of issues
might we might have we might have a
class imbalance we might have some data
transformation that needs to be carried
out all that will be covered in machine
learning engineering so basically you
need to focus one machine learning
algorithm data engineering on the other
hand if I give you a very simple and
understanding it is basically about data
infrastructure so right from capturing
the data it's getting stored how you
will make sure that data Integrity
quality is maintained and it is readily
available to end users and those end
users could be probably some
stakeholders which are looking at the
data from a business intelligence angle
or probably machine learning Engineers
or data scientists who want to utilize
that data and build certain applications
or who they want to try some to solve
some problems so that's what data
engineering will come and then you have
ai architect or AI developer when you
have ai architect in in in for the
matter of fact would be such people who
will build entire end to end
infrastructure they will tell you how
the entire infrastructure should be it
could be as simple as deciding how the
data will move based on multiple nodes
how it will be distributed on the
multiple uh hdf is probably distribution
that we talked about or probably how it
works on this our other has to move from
from one repository and then then give
the user end result which will consist
of applying multiple models and then
then making sure that the machine
learning model versioning is taking
place and all this infrastructure part
will be designed by AI architect AI
developer on the other hand if you talk
about more on on a deep learning side
they can create some deep learning
modules they can create models which can
solve some problem data science as a as
a field if you talk about so uh the job
role that we generally talk about is of
data scientist and data scientist is
somebody who has kind of will cover
these different Spectrum in a sense that
they would be pretty they should be very
good at statistical analysis machine
learning algorithm any given problem uh
is is there they should be able to aware
that how they how they can take it and
solve it entirely they can expect with
the different models they should know
how to do research on the problem all
that would be part of your data
scientist job role so this is how we can
separate one from the another
okay I appreciate that and and
when you say separate from one another
it's also the the fluidity like you like
you've seen in your career of
beginning in one place and moving to
another as you gain skills and as you
follow your interests passions and new
technologies so uh is a dynamic field
where people can keep uh their interests
fresh and vigorous
um to get started within the area you
need to have
um a kind of Suite of skills a set of
skills that give you an overview
of all the different aspects of AI and
ml so that you understand where any
given problem fits into that
environment and so that you can be
adaptable yeah that's good and that's
correct
so can you take us through how and we
had a question already in the chat about
um
a couple questions about what kind of
background you would need in statistics
and maths to get started and how
um
what you would learn in a program like
this in terms of Mass statistic and the
the programming capabilities of the
foundation
so as you uh as as you you have put it
across on this slide this is a very apt
way of looking at it you once you are
entering in this particular field you
should have some foundational skills
which consist of statistics and
Mathematics now why do we need
statistics and Mathematics I would say
two-fold reason mostly one is that some
of the statistical Technique we use for
the data preparation purpose whether you
are using a deep Learning Network or or
machine learning doesn't matters you
need to prepare the data pre-process
some of the techniques are pretty useful
over there which comes from statistics
another which is another part which is
very important is these machine learning
algorithms they require a lot of
tweaking and and those tweaking you can
do only if you understand the
mathematics behind it that how changing
up one particular parameter will change
the entire model performance or the
output and for that purpose you should
understand the mathematical intuition we
behind an algorithm so some statistics
and maths I would say is is pretty much
important and Mathematics is not
something which you have to understand
at the PHD level I would say that it's a
eighth grade math we start with and then
we go to differential calculus which
probably in the 10th grade or 12th grade
you study anyway so that's what is in
the statistics and maths and then in in
order to carry out these analysis you
need a a tool and python is one of the
tool which is a go-to tool for for all
machine learning implementation so
Python and libraries you should learn
about them then once you have that
foundational skills done then you can
move toward machine learn towards
machine learning algorithm so you can
start with the supervised unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning
semi-supervised these will consist of a
bunch of algorithms which you should
learn because you need to experiment
with these algorithms on the data you
don't know which algorithm will work for
you so there's a a number of algorithms
available understand the how it what's
the concept understand the math behind
it and also understand how to implement
on the data using python or you can
choose any other tool as for that matter
but python is the best tool we have then
once you finish your machine learning
then you go to the advanced topic uh
where we talk about deep learning which
is basically building uh machines which
is uh which is having some kind of
artificial intelligence in it so that's
where deep learning come into the
picture which consists of neural
networks and in that's a field where
even generative adversarial Network
which is one type of generative AI which
is part of that so you learn about them
also and any recent advancement which is
happening you need to be uh uh very
abreast with all those uh advancements
which are happening so you need to study
a lot it's an ongoing process like Gans
came few years back and we were thinking
it is it is out of this world and then
within Gan itself a lot of new uh
techniques have come up then computer
vision NLP speech recognition this is
all advanced topic that you should know
and once you once you've covered all
this then you can say that you have no
thorough understanding of machine
learning deep learning Concepts and you
can solve some problems
thank you um I just want to mention for
the folks who have put questions and
please keep putting your questions in Q
a we will be getting to those in the Q a
session toward the end of the webinar
and there's a lot of great questions in
there
um right now I want to ask a question of
you and the audience however and this
question is what is stopping you
um what has stopped you up until now
from finding a program and getting
enrolled in it if you're interested in
becoming a practitioner in the in the AI
and ml field and you've looked at
different programs what are the things
that you 've seen that you felt were
lacking
so is it because you you don't get a
comprehensive uh view of all the
different skills that uh spoke of is it
because you don't feel you'd have
examples to show your new skills off is
it because of the way that those
programs are delivered or is it because
of finding time in your work schedule
I'm going to leave this open just for
another five four three
two one
and pretty even distribution of answers
today so uh certainly the the top answer
is
feeling that you need practical exposure
something that will give you examples
that you can use to show off how you've
used your new skills how you use the
different tools uh in Ai and ml practice
and then finding time in your work
schedule along with the other concerns
so with that I'm going to move
to our program here
oops sorry
this is the AI and ml bootcamp from
Caltech
and Caltech uh is the California
Institute of Technology their Center for
technology and management education I'll
describe it a little bit but it the part
of Caltech that
provides a knowledge transfer from their
institution to Industry work with many
different
companies and organizations that come to
come to Caltech and say you're doing
great work research you're developing
cutting-edge Technologies you're
exploring
the depths of practice we want our
people to be able to do some of the same
things so I'll take form ctme to
transfer that knowledge into industry
and as a consequence the programs are
designed to help people become capable
practitioners in the different areas
including Ai and ml
um they came to us to help them deliver
this program to the public
through our platform which simply
learned online boot camp mod uh platform
and that provides you with hands-on
experience through a virtual machine
environment that you get to use on the
platform along with live virtual
classrooms where instructors like I'm a
teacher uh work with you to take you
through those exercises
help you um
succeed and understand
how to develop
using those AIML tools it's a program
that is available online 24 7. so
between the scheduled classes you can
access the system anytime to do your
prep work your projects your homework
um so that it's flexible to fit the the
needs of a working professional and it's
a six-month program we say that you need
to devote about 10 hours a week
to it uh alright King can You
kind of um comment on
how people divide their time between
what happens in the classroom
virtual classroom versus what happens in
between
how it goes is basically most of the
things will be covered in the classroom
over the weekend and then what they do
is and generally that's what we
encourage also is is we give some kind
of uh probably kind of a case study they
can work on the over the week days if
they get time or probably some small
chunk of reading materials which we
encourage to just to gain some
understanding it might require 15-20
minutes 30 minutes you know in a week
not beyond that but most of the stuff
that we do is we cover in the classroom
understanding that majority of them are
working professional they don't get much
time over the weekdays so what we plan
is that even if we have to study
something over the weekdays and it
should not be more than 20 30 minutes
beyond that we don't provide anything
but generally what people they do is
they they work with us on the weekends
and on all the weekdays they like to
work on a problem they they studied it
they come back with their questions
which again we saw in the classroom
that's how it goes us yeah and and in
the classroom it's not just lectures
it's not the the format that we have
here where
I mean teen and I are talking to you but
it's the format where you're interacting
with your instructor uh going through
making sure that
you can raise your questions and you can
do the exercises along with the
instructor so that's a a great aspect we
did have a question in the chat that
is it really possible for somebody
without a technical background to engage
in this program and succeed in six
months
I would say yes because we start from
scratch we have a refresher on building
those uh technical aptitude menu so we
start with that so you will be taught
about basic python some mathematics we
start from scratch and we explain in a
way that anyone can understand that's
how it goes basically when I talk about
a mathematical concept don't think of it
as something which has been written in a
very uh complex Manner and then I will
just simply say this is what it doesn't
need to understand it or any training
for that matter so what happens is we
explain you very Crux of it why a
particular concept is important even if
it's mathematical and we break it down
in a very simple component so that
refresher is there and that way you will
be ready for understanding these
Concepts in a better manner in the later
classes and you will be able to
implement on the data so yes you will
succeed in in finishing this particular
program even if you don't have technical
knowledge at the moment
and
the result of the program is a
certificate issued by Caltech uh Center
for technology management and education
they hold us responsible for delivering
their curriculum in a way that they can
put their name on your certificate and
certify that you've gained the skills uh
that this program uh offers you also
receive along the way many certificates
for elements of the program as you
complete each module uh you unlock a
certificate for that and then the final
Capstone project that we'll talk about
unlocks your your Caltech certificate
Caltech will offer you up to 22 CEUs so
if you are in a
industry that requires
ongoing continuing education and proof
of that or if your employer requires
that
you you get those CEUs continuing
education units issued by Caltech
you also get membership in the Caltech
online ctme Circle which is an online
Alumni Association gives you the ability
to network with all the folks who've
taken similar programs from Caltech ctme
go to events that are run by the the
ctme folks and you also get recognized
that an online convocation
which
allows you to invite friends and family
to see you get recognized by name for
your accomplishment so all of these are
some of the benefits that you get from
this program
talk about Caltech Caltech is
I mean she mentioned it's a very
prestigious honor to be working with
them they have been around for 130 years
they're not part of the University of
California Earth California State
University system they're an independent
or um entity
they specialize in Graduate Studies and
research they run a number of different
Laboratories including the
jet propulsion lab which is where they
build satellites and space probes for
NASA to launch and many people have
earned Nobel prizes for the research
they've done at Caltech and many more
have
done research elsewhere to win Nobel
prizes and then chosen to move to
Caltech to continue that research so
it's consistently one of the top five
universities in the world
one of the greatest concentrations of
Brilliant Minds in the world there's no
no accident that when they decided to
make the sitcom The Big Bang Theory
about
the quirks of really brilliant people
that they chose to set it at Caltech
because that's where you find really
brilliant people and Caltech on your
resume is going to be something that
people will recognize
um so
again we're extremely proud that they
chose to work with us and we're very
honored
the eligibility for this program is
pretty open you do have to have some as
we've discussed prior knowledge of
mathematics and program it doesn't have
to be at a very uh advanced level where
the program's open to anyone with a high
school diploma
and at least 18 years of age as long as
they do have that knowledge and
background in math and programming uh we
prefer that people have two or more
years of work experience can you comment
on the value of the work experience uh
classes
oh work experience helps in a sense that
you will be readily available uh will be
able to map the the concepts to various
problem that you can solve in your
domain so when you come with a work
experience I'll tell the I'll tell you
the advantages one that you'll be able
to correlate with the problem in a
better manner second is that although we
are talking about AIML uh it looks like
a very Advanced part but eventually it
works like a project only so people who
come with the experience they know how
how they have worked on different
projects in their their organizations
and just like any other project this
will also move so you will have a
problem you will have a project timeline
you will have uh different components of
a typical project that goes into so
those are the things which will be
helpful in terms of mapping out over
here that's what I would say
yeah and when we say work experience
that doesn't mean work experience in Ai
and ml that would be self-defeating
because that would be a catch-22 where
you you'd have to have the experience
before you could train in the field we
mean General work experience so even if
you've come you're coming straight out
of high school
um and don't have other outside work
experience
that will work but if you have work
experience whatever level it is from
being a
executive or manager within a
corporation to having experience uh you
know in retail that type of thing that
all of that gives you the perspective of
how Ai and ml could be used the Working
World so
we'll talk about how this program gets
you job ready and
this is what happens in the six months
um I mean can you kind of tell us
why this is built in this kind of Step
step-by-step staircase
to take people from zero to
proficiency
sure so the idea here about having this
particular uh uh set of courses word
that was that we can start from a very
basic building block and gradually take
you to the complex problem solving using
ml algorithms or or deep learning
algorithm so the idea was that we should
be able to start at a very basic level
and gradually move to the complexity of
the different algorithms which are there
so it starts with the orientation
session from Caltech Ai and ml bootcamp
where you'll be explained uh what this
program is all about and what is are the
outcome of this program then you go to
the section which is called introduction
to artificial intelligence here we talk
about what exactly is AI and what are
the some applications that you might
have experienced in the recent past and
we also talk about different use cases
coming from multiple Industries so it
gives you idea that how AI is getting
utilized in different industry different
sectors different verticals and then we
also talk about whether it's different
tools and techniques which is probably
important in terms of building your
career in artificial intelligence
then once that kind of a foundation is
done in terms of setting under the
understanding of AI we talk about
applied data science with python now the
supplied data science with python is
basically
uh designed for understanding that data
in a data manner because you might have
heard a lot that all these algorithms
required huge amount of data to work
well so here we talk about how to work
with data how to do data wrangling or a
data munging we talk about basically
data are pretty processing that we do
some kind of transformation aggregation
or probably some feature engineering
that we do these are some little
technical terms probably some of you
have not heard don't worry about that
part but just telling you that these are
the some some of the components of ml
Project Life Cycle and we teach you how
to uh work with the data using these
Concepts and how to implement eventually
with python so any of these uh section
that we're gonna talk about uh which
I'll explain a little later is is
basically we teach you a concept then we
take a problem we solve the problem
using python so entirely Hands-On which
starts
from applied data science with python
then we move to machine learning where
we teach you about different machine
learning algorithms again the the format
is this we teach you a concept uh what
it is capable of what is the concept and
then we give you a mathematical
intuition behind it that what is a math
and math when we are talking about in a
very simple manner we explain and then
we take a problem or a case study and
while solving the case study we also
talk about that what will be the
different stages in terms of
implementing that concept and what kind
of challenges you might come across and
also how do you fine tune a particular
model so that's how machine learning
will be taught to you entirely so
different kinds of algae rhythm then
once you are done with machine learning
algorithms will move to deep learning
with Keras and tensorflow so we talk
about deep learning algorithms and for
the implementation purpose we use Keras
and tensorflow which is a python
framework developed for deep learning
algorithms so here we talk about uh
concept of neural network how it is
created it was created by getting
impression from
biological neurons so neural networks
how do they work and what kind of
different types of neural networks are
there like when we want to do image
classification or object detection then
we have a network called CNN or
convolutional neural network or if you
want to work with the text data or any
kind of sequential data then there is a
RNN which is recurrent neural network so
all these networks will be taught to you
and what will be explained to you that
why do we need them and why can't we
solve that with a traditional neural
network so we'll about all that and then
we move to Advanced deep learning and
machine learning sorry Machine Vision
which is basically uh talks about recent
advancement in deep learning so here we
talk about generative algorithms like
Gans or it could be a variational auto
encoders we talk about different use
cases also like image to image
translations or we talk about image
Generations as well so that's what we
talk about in advanced deep learning
again the idea is to explain your
concept entirely with the mathematics
behind it and then Implement on a given
problem using python and then eventually
once this entire course is completed you
will be asked to solve a Capstone so
Capstone over here is something which
will test your understanding right from
the applied data science and till
machine learning or deep learning
implementation so this is a very
comprehensive Capstone which is there
and it uh we are you're given option of
of a couple of Capstone which you can
choose from generally and it comes from
different industry different verticals
even during the each individual courses
which are there say machine learning or
deep learning you will have a course and
project where you will be given certain
options like probably two or three
projects and you can choose one so you
might have a a recommendation engine
project where you need to build a
recommendation engine from scratch or it
could be a returning path retinopathy
project where you need to identify a
particular issue in the in in a patient
based on the scans that we have received
of their eyes so so those are the
projects which are available as a course
and project and eventually you work on
the Capstone
in addition to that you also have
electives switched which is uh which you
can choose any one of them or all of
them your wish and it's included in the
course itself so you have statistical
essential for data science which talks
about different statistical analysis
which you should be a which which you
can apply in data science NLP and speech
recognition uh working with a speech and
probably solving speech to text or text
to speech kind of uh problems over there
reinforcement learning what they are
what they're capable of and where you
can utilize them and then you also get
Caltech Ai and ml bootcamp Master Class
where probably you get some industry
experts or you get from Caltech uh some
some expert on the matter subject matter
experts that we talk about and they come
they share their knowledge on on these
Concepts and what kind of challenges
they have faced how did they solve or
what are the good practices that's what
you get entirely from the program great
thank you and then to to re reiterate
the electives are included in the cost
of the program so that they don't cost
extra they are a way for you to kind of
customize your experience based on what
you're interested in and the time you
have available so we always recommend
people
take those
um
it when you say that you're going to
learn these tools and Platforms in this
program
you don't just read about them or watch
videos about them you have to apply them
on the live Virtual Lab environment
right
that's correct and the entire life cycle
of a machine learning project will
consist of different components each
component will require different uh kind
of packages so we cover all these
packages and we introduce them whenever
it's required we explain to them we
explain them why they are required and
what's the purpose of it so you get to
learn about matplotlab which is a
visualization library in Python flask
which will help you in terms of creating
some apis for the deployment purpose
Keras is a deep learning framework
tensorflow SQL and so all these
libraries will be taught to you and they
will be explained why they need why
there is a need of them and how to use
them
appreciate that
so we've mentioned the Capstone project
a few times and and just to kind of put
that into context
as Emma King said you are going to do
course end projects throughout the
program so you'll be doing labs and then
at the end of the module
one or more projects
confirm that you have the understanding
of that module
and these are building up towards the
last part of the program which is to
choose a challenge or a case study or
industry based problem
from several different domains and
choose the one that interests you spends
several weeks working on that developing
Your solution
how does that process work in terms of
mentorship of the instructor at that
point
basically it goes like this we prepare
them for a real world scenario that's
what the whole idea is that they could
solve a real world uh problem so
gradually what we do we introduce
different components we start teaching
them different analysis different uh
requirements which we will have and
eventually the Capstone will will take
an end-to-end implementation of all
those Concepts that they have learned
from day one so it actually tests their
capability on the entire machine
learning ecosystem that we talk about
right from a problem statement and
eventually giving the outcome so it's
pretty comprehensive and once we solve
the Capstone once you solve the Capstone
you get a lot of confidence also that
once a real world problem is given to
you how will you take it and how it you
will give the entire conclusion to the
end user the stakeholders so that's
where capitals are pretty useful very
beneficial and I've seen also in the
past students have derived a lot of
confidence once they have solved us
one of the important things is the last
point on the slide mentions first and
last points both mentioned
something that goes into your portfolio
so as you're doing work in this program
you're building up examples that are
going into a GitHub portfolio that you
can then share with people including
people who are evaluating you for a
promotion or a new job and show examples
of the work you've done
so here are some examples of projects
that you end up as as artifacts and
you might use
you might choose from the social media
domain or the e-commerce domain the
manufacturing domain educational
technology Health Care
this kind of illustrates how AI is not
just restricted to one particular
industry right
that is correct and that's the beauty of
it uh and and and one thing that I
iterate in the classroom is that uh you
take a you take a particular algorithm
and and uh same algorithm I can use in
different vertical different industry
problem statement will change but the
underlying concept will remain same from
the mathematics perspective from machine
learning perspective that's the beauty
of it so once you learn these algorithms
you'll be able to solve different kinds
of problem but you should also get some
kind of a practice on it or probably you
should know what kind of problem we are
solving and that's where these projects
are pretty useful you get to work with
the project which is coming from
e-commerce or probably manufacturing
ethics social media Healthcare so this
will this will be a good mix in terms of
understanding different kinds of problem
coming from different industry and how
to solve them
thank you
so I want to mention that one of the
reasons that Caltech came to Simply
learn is because we offer a ecosystem of
support for Learners so we have a
program manager who interfaces with
Caltech make sure that we're delivering
this program to their specifications
um when you enroll you enroll with a
number of other people on the same date
that becomes your cohort
we assign a success manager to the
cohort who Shepherds you and your your
fellow Learners through make sure that
you're keeping up with the pace of the
program uh answering any questions or
helping you with any remedial material
you need
um instructors work with you
succeed in individual individual courses
and so circular commenting would be
helping you through the given course and
answering questions
available between classes to take
questions through the community feature
on our website the uh
other aspect is the people that you're
in the cohort with you're learning peers
your other fellow Learners who will be
able to provide you Mutual support we
hope that
somebody came to you with a question of
you did you understand what the lecture
said last Saturday you'd be able to
answer that help them with that just as
they would turn around and help you with
uh similar questions you posed
curriculum and the resources the
platform itself
videos content and
ebooks and other
tools including the Virtual Lab
environment are all designed to help you
succeed so this kind of complete
ecosystem
is intended to give you the best chance
of completing the program successfully
gaining these skills at this point I am
going to um
stop sharing my screen and allow I'm a
team to
share his
and show us a little bit about the
actual learning environment
no
hey so our elements that you you will
get the access for now once you log in
different programs out there and we're
going to talk about Caltech AML bootcamp
is what we are talking about so once you
have that access to given to you you can
go to the program and this is
a pretty nice LMS in terms of its quite
comprehensive so first of all it gives
you uh track of how much course you have
covered already and how much is spending
so that you can keep a track of it and
you will know how far you have to go in
terms of completing the course and then
it starts with the all different
sections that we have covered I have
explained to you earlier so course one
is your orientation that I explained to
you then close to is Introduction to
artificial intelligence python for data
science apply data science with python
and so on and then eventually Capstone
projects so this this all will be listed
over here
and then once you click on any of the
cores like I am going to machine
learning now I have already completed
rest of it so I click on this so you get
this particular section over here where
first of all you get a self learning
section over here once you click on it
it gives you
a bunch of videos over here which is
just for yourself learning purpose it's
not something which you have to do it
mandatorily it is something which is
there for your health purpose so you can
actually go through uh some of the
sessions over here like course
introduction is there probably a demo on
the on the Jupiter lab sometimes you
also get some explanation of the topic
this is just for your health purpose and
you can you can read that and you can
come to the classroom uh with with some
kind of understanding of it then once
you have your live classes it will be it
can be accessed over here so you can
click on the live class and it will give
you the list of all the classes that you
are enrolled for so it will say my
classes and you will get the datewise
description over here past classes will
come and then once the session is over
suppose you want to go back to certain
Concepts that has been dealt in the
classroom so you want to watch the
recordings those recordings will also
will be available over here in the same
page and you can re-watch it whenever
you want
then
uh you also have assessment page over
here if you see so this is this is where
uh once you finish your this particular
course uh some problem have been given
like if you see here it talks about a
mercedes-bench Greener manufacturing uh
project then income qualification which
is from World Bank Healthcare book
rental recommendation so these are the
projects which has been given to you and
you're supposed to solve one of them in
order to get your certificate done for
this particular course which is machine
learning so if you actually look at it
you are given
some options over here which one
whichever you want to choose you can
choose and uh and in the classroom when
you are working with the trainer so
trainers will be using some some
PowerPoint presentation or probably some
PDFs and they will also be working on
the data so all that you can find under
reference material over here so you
don't have to go anywhere else
everything is available over here you
can simply download the eBooks from here
which are the presentations used in the
classroom and the code books and the
data set which will be used in the
classroom some of the data which is part
of your project that also is available
over here you can download it one more
thing to add here once you go to any
project the project description is there
in terms of WhatsApp problem statement
and also what are the tasks that you are
supposed to carry out so this is all
given over here now when you are working
on when you're going through the live
sessions one thing we told you that it's
a Hands-On session so the lab also is
integrated in your
LMS itself you don't have to download
anything on your system simply through a
browser you can access the lab and you
can start using it whenever you are your
trainer is asking you to do so this lab
looks like this you will have your
notebooks which you can upload over here
and you can work with that like in this
example I'm giving you a little
understanding of the lab I'm talking
about a analysis called regression which
is taught to you under machine learning
and under this analysis this is what
will be taught to you entirely so you'll
have a use case and then you'll have
different concepts covered over here
this is the entire regression analysis
done over here with different concepts
so we tell you what's the agenda then we
take a problem statement that this is
what the problem statement is and we
have been given a data and the idea is
to understand regression and apply on
this particular data to solve a
particular problem so then the notebook
will consist of the code section as well
which will be given to you in advance
you can simply run with the trainer and
the trainer will explain each line
entirely what it's doing and why we are
writing and how we are running it so
then we'll load the data we'll explain
you what we are doing over here entirely
these codes will be available to you
suppose I make some changes in the code
book I write my own code something that
you have asked for some clarification
you need it or something you wanted me
to Simply run on the data and show it to
you so I'll run it over here I'll add my
piece of code over here and then after
the session ends I will share this code
book with you how do I share I'll
explain in this in in a bit then we'll
finish this entire
detailed uh
Notebook on the regression analysis how
it works and what kind of conclusion you
can draw different concepts will be
covered over here and as I mentioned
this notebook will be available to you
in the LMS itself or it will be shared
post the session in case if I make some
changes to it and then if I'm sharing
the
I'm sharing the code book I can share
here on the community so this community
is pretty useful now here not only I can
share all the files or relevant uh
reading material with you I can also
interact with you like if suppose we can
so I'm taking sessions and weekdays you
are studying and you need some help from
any of the trainer probably you want to
interact with the fellow Learners you
can log into community and you can
access to the the code files that I have
been sharing also you can interact with
the other Learners so that if you have
some doubt you can clarify in case if
some kind of technical issue happens you
need some help so there is a help
section over here which is available
24x7 you can simply click on that and
the help will be on your way
and once you finish everything then you
go to your certificate section it will
get unlocked you can download it and
keep it with you
that's how the LMS works and just to add
or summarize the entire thing uh this is
a pretty comprehensive LMS so at one
place you get everything you don't have
to download any of the components
separately everything is here the data
part the lab part problem statements the
code book The presentations everything
is in under one single
umbrella you can simply use it so that's
how LMS works and this is a small demo
on that
thank you very much for that and
let me
go back to our
rotation here
all right
so as I mentioned the program is under
the supervision of Caltech ctme they
design the curriculum work with us to
develop the delivery method uh Rick
Hefner is the executive director who
oversees the program personally and
he's got 40 years of experience in
academics and Industry and
um
got a lot of particular expertise in how
industry requires individuals to be
trained
again Caltech ctme takes a lot of people
who are working in companies and trains
them upskills them and this is part of
their program for that so we're very
again proud to be part of that with them
so learner outcomes you will be learning
alongside people a lot of whom are
working professionals that may come from
companies like
Wells Fargo or Target or Boeing these
people come from different environments
so it's not just
technology environment
I.T or software
manufacturing Healthcare and Pharma a
banking Financial Services pretty much
every industry as we discussed
um how does how does that kind of
mixed environment or that kind of
diverse class environment
help learners
well diversity really helps over here
because uh people come from different
industry different background they share
their uh problems their real world uh
issues that they are thinking to solve
with these algorithms so uh every every
person will come up with their own
issues their own problem their own
challenges they will discuss in the
classroom lot of people actually bring
their actual problems in the from the
workplace and they they kind of explain
that this is what they are trying to
solve and if if some of us can help them
in terms of doing some experimentation
so that's pretty useful because you get
to know about different kinds of actual
problem that people are people trying to
solve from different industry different
vertical gives you a pretty good
understanding of how same Pro same
algorithm can be applied to a different
domain as well so that's what the
benefit is working with the diverse
group of people
thank you
and here are a few of the learner
reviews you'll see a number of these on
our website and I'll in a few minutes
I'll share the URL for our program
course page
um
this is people are acknowledging the
value of the teaching methods of the
material and getting into the advanced
topic so we're hoping that those of you
who enroll will become part of our list
of
testimonials like this
we also offer career assist service so
we don't do job placement or job
guarantees but you do get a chance to
work with um
people who will give you expert help in
job search so everyone who enrolls gets
access to our webinar programs and
of course the program itself gives you
project experience that builds up your
portfolio
the job assists Services specifically
include
premium membership to the talent Inc
a job portal
resume review and rewrite Services which
allow you to collaborate with a writer
and
develop your resume so that it can pass
through AI screening
and get onto someone's desk and still
look good and then one-on-one interview
service which gives you the chance to do
live
interview prep the different kinds of
interviews you'll have to pass from
phone screens to Tech interviews to
corporate fit interviews so
all of those are available to you for
six months after you earn your
certificate
and the program fees are nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine dollars US
can be financed on an Emi basis at 880 a
month
if you have an employer who helps you
with uh education expenses and tuition
reimbursement please ask them about
eligibility for this program
and to get started you email us at ask
us simplylearn.net so I will be putting
that into the chat
based on what you have heard so far are
you interested
enrolling in the program
I'll start this poll
okay
put that information into the chat that
I mentioned
and I will in the poll now
about two-thirds a little more than
two-thirds of our audience today are
interested in joining the program
and what I'll do is I will share with
you this
steps
the next cohort starts at the end of the
month on 31 July you can take the
induction class I think there's a
induction class you can take a week in
advance or you can take it the day of
um the induction class being the two
hour orientation session and then the
classes themselves start
um again weekend
four hour Saturday for our Sunday
during that six month period with some
breaks
you submit your application at ask us at
simplylearn.net will verify that you
have your high school diploma or
equivalent that you're 18 years of age
we'll ask you some questions about your
programming and math knowledge
and any work experience you might have
and based on that they'll offer you
admission we say hurry because in order
for instructors to be able to give
sufficient time and attention to each
learner we limit the cohorts to about 25
to 30 people
per cohort we run these cohorts monthly
so
um
we expect that if you want to get
started with the end of July cohort
please contact us right away and with
that in mind what time frame are you
looking at if you're interested in this
program
and I'll leave this opening for just
another five seconds
or
three
three two one
and
more than half of our audience want to
get started either uh end of July or
maybe August September
for those of you looking further down
the road please do contact us and ask us
at simplylearn.net or through the
webpage because we can then keep and try
in touch with you about future cohorts
and answer other questions you might
have
um
we have a question about a discount and
I had forgotten to mention that your
bonus for attending this webinar is a
discount off of the program fees uh
contact our learning consultant said ask
us at simplylearn.net to find out what
the amount of that discount is
this point let's take your questions and
answers
and I'm going to go into the Q a
I know that we won't have time to get to
all of them but I hope that we'll get
through quite a few so uh first question
we have a veteran do we have chapter 31
or other programs for veterans ask us at
simplylearn.net can help you with that
um we do work with different government
agencies
so they may be able to help you with
veteran
discounts basic skills required to start
the program we have talked about that
um
is it in person or just offline learning
so
um
the uh to interpret that question
none of this is done in person
physically this is all done online but
you're doing it in person with the
instructors on the weekends correct
that is correct so there'll be a live
session where I this which is our
instructor-led session so think of it as
a classroom but it would be virtually
done
uh how are simple learning Caltech
integrated so we're the delivery partner
for the Caltech program if you take the
um
master classes
some of those are delivered by Caltech
uh
faculty or instructors who will share
with you their Advanced research or
other topics in the industry so
um
the classes are generally taught by
industry experts like I'm a teen and
master classes include Caltech faculty
is the Capstone project an individual or
a group exercise
the Capstone project is that an
individual project or as an individual
project individual entirely
um again you have a weekly meeting with
your instructor to keep on track and
answer your questions
um I think we talked about different
companies there's a you take a look at
any
job board Glassdoor indeed dice
you will and search for AIML job
openings you will see the range of
companies
pretty much concludes everybody
um
so we had a question from an anonymous
attendee who said the world generated
enormous quantity of data from the
pandemic
that data set would be ideal for using
AI
from analysis modeling predicting
I didn't see any such use can you
explain why so can you give a
perspective on the the way all that data
has been used
see even if it's getting utilized that
will not be in public domain it's all
highly confidential data probably some
of the findings can come out that also
depends if an organization want to share
mostly ngos are probably a government
house a government departments they
share those findings uh uh and an
organization which has found something
some leverage over the data they will
not be sharing in open forums because
they don't want to uh let their
competitors know in a very simple
fashion against sales but if you
actually see the kind of accuracy we are
actually getting in different domain you
talk about computer vision you talk
about uh Speech you talk about NLP
application it's huge so if you actually
look at it you will realize that there
is a drastic improvement in these
applications result
no
um I can mention you you had talked
about restaurants previously and I can
give an example from uh fast food
industry Wendy's
in the pandemic they developed an online
a mobile ordering platform so that
people would be able to order their food
in advance and pick it up at the
drive-through without waiting
they discovered that because of this
mobile app they were gaining a lot of
data about the customer behavior that
they had before so they now instead of
you showing up at the counter at the
Wendy's or going through the
drive-through and being relatively
Anonymous and now knew who you were
because you were part of the the app and
you had a
maybe a rewards point system
um and therefore they could start doing
things like offering you
um time of day-based deals things that
based on were based on your buying
patterns and all of these kinds of
recommendation systems
analyzes uh are based on AI and ML and
then the the other aspect of that was
they were able to then
use this data to improve the operations
within their stores so that they could
predict patterns of usage in Staffing
levels and that type of thing so it's
really quite uh an amazing area
we don't see it we don't think about it
but it's there
um
what resource Fatima says what resources
should I start off with to learn or
practice Ai and ml
our resources when you're talking about
they'll be like you will have the tools
and the techniques so when you talk
about tools you need to pick up python
you need to pick up uh different tools
which will be useful within python to
apply uh on on a project and on the
technique side you need to learn about
different algorithms if I give you a
very broad outlines that's how it would
be
and Kelly asks a related question are
you required to have the math and
statistics and python skills prior to
entering the program or does the program
cover that as you move forward
our program has a I think it has a
refresher on that python for data
science which is there so python will be
taken care and Mathematics is something
which we when we once we're teaching the
algorithm we explain you what's the maps
behind it and a very simple term so if
you if you know a little bit of
mathematics that you have done in the
past it wouldn't be a problem to
understand it but if you can actually
take little effort and and go through
some Basics that will be very useful to
you
Davidson
asked what the job demand is in Ai and
ML and the chances of getting employed
and before you answer that I mean I mean
we there's a
you can ask us at simplylearn.net we'll
be able to talk to you about the success
rate for our
program graduates but in your
perspective of machine what is the
environment for
job demand for people in this field
well there's a huge scope I would say uh
if you if you actually simply go on any
of the job website that you talk about
including LinkedIn I would say is the
consistent job demand in this particular
domain right from the basic level entry
level and to the advanced level where
you need experience professionals so it
could be as simple as a data analyst you
are starting your career which is for
probably for as an entry point or
probably you are joining in between a
stage where you are a machine learning
engineer or probably a data scientist so
it depends on which path you are
choosing what level you are joining but
if you talk about any company today you
talk about uh traditionally Banking and
an ITV we're talking about utilizing a
lot of data but now you talk about any
of the industry manufacturing you talk
about renewable energy you talk about uh
service industry they all utilize data
big time and they need people who can
actually work on these Concepts
the duration of the courses who had a
question uh it's a six-month course you
have access to the program class
recordings and that type of thing for
six months after you complete the course
but the other material you have
pretty much lifetime access to be able
to look at videos and and uh ebooks and
that type of thing
um I believe that's correct
check that with the people and learning
Consultants
um
is the program graded in any way will
will ask the question is the program
graded
that could be created like every course
and project you will once you will
submit it will be graded and based on
that your certificate will be unlocked
so it's more of a pass fail type yeah
pass and fail grading in a sense that's
that's uh that's the only thing it's not
like you'll be getting different grades
uh it's details about instructors there
may be some on our web page you can also
ask our learning Consultants to share
some of that with you
the time slots for weekend classes four
hours Saturday for our Sunday these are
generally scheduled at 8am
Pacific time is that correct that would
be
noon Eastern
it's it's oriented towards the U.S
market
that's correct it will be at that point
in time only
um
Kelly asked a question if you get into
the program and it turns out to be too
difficult uh what is the policy for
dropping the program I would ask people
to ask us at simplywin.net because uh
you want to make sure that
you get evaluated before you enter the
program to feel that you you have
the best chance of success this is one
of the reasons why we do that initial
evaluation of your application
um really to to enter this program you
want to number one feel confident you
have a background for it number two the
aptitude for it and number three the
dedication to it so I will ask you some
of those questions up front but you can
ask that specific question of our
learning Consultants
um
is it possible to finish the program
faster than six months
so
uh
I'm asking can you comment on what
happened in a sense that it's a live
virtual class so if class is scheduled
for six months you will go through that
you cannot do it in advance
yeah so it it we kind of help people go
through the program at a a constant Pace
because that gives the maximum chance of
success
um
yes there are projects in the field of
fintech
um interesting story The we had a
webinar and it's in our past library of
webinars uh with the founder of uh zest
money in India she
described how Ai and ml created the
fintech industry and the the idea that
if you're at a point of sale
and want to get a micro credit
loan to cover the cost of something
might be a 50 item and we want to be
able to get that credit extended to you
there would be no way for human beings
to make that decision on the Fly for you
um
whereas the AI system can do that by
looking at far more than just your
credit score or your bank balances it
can look at many other factors about you
so if you give it permission to do that
it can make
better decisions
extend credit to you than any human
being could do and it can do it in
seconds or so
um
here's a question for you MIT uh there
are many co-pilots available for
programming
is there any such available thing for AI
and ml development
assistant tools co-pilots
um
in the sense that when you are working
on a project basically applications when
you are building it there you're
required to code a lot you are required
to put all the logic and everything you
need to provide that data so you have
certain Frameworks which can help you
with that if that's what you're saying
as a co-pilot uh if that's what you're
asking so there are the ones which are
available but they can they can just do
us to a certain extent then you have to
sit down and you have to work on your
own
we have a question about how many people
are in the cohort and is there an online
Forum so the as I mentioned we try to
limit the cohorts to 25 to 30 people
um and then the online forum is as uh I
mean he demonstrated there it's a
thread-based forum uh you'll see your
instructor posting threads about the
course when it starts about each class
when each class finishes you can raise a
create a thread about a particular topic
that you want to discuss or get help
with there's also the 24x7 help desk if
you have those questions but
um
Kelly asked do we have to attend the
class while it's live and then someone
else asks if we miss a class on a
weekend uh due to some other
life requirement how is that handled
well basically uh first of all you are
supposed to at least cover 75 percent of
the classes uh virtual classes I think
and the second thing is if you missed
that particular class for some reason
the recordings will be available you can
go through it and before the next
session starts completed so that uh you
will be in aligned with what trainer is
teaching you and then you can continue
a bit of a question about someone who
just joined how to get the recorded
version if you registered for this
webinar you will receive a follow-up
email with a link to this recording
and
how can we introduce this kind of course
in countries like Costa Rica this course
is uh this course for similar courses
from Simply learn and Caltech are
available in Costa Rica you are in fact
able to take this course in almost any
country that you have the ability to log
onto the internet so
provided you can take instruction in
English
you can attend this course from Costa
Rica it's the
no reason
or no limitation or no reason to wait so
uh just to add that to that's to it now
I remember I had a session the Celtic
program itself a couple of students
joined and it was 2 am for for at their
place 2 am in the morning
yeah so we have people who are dedicated
to doing yeah doing that
um
we had a question about in the cases
where AI has failed what are some of the
reasons why AI fails
yeah it fails are there could be
multiple reasons because one could be
that a lack of sufficient uh training
examples that is a main reason to start
with sometimes it might also happen that
there's a lot of
uh changes happening as we are capturing
the data so the model deteriorates we
call it as a model drift sometimes the
data drift happens so those are the main
reason uh why the AI might fail in
certain cases to give you a quick
example you talk about I build a model
which can predict what will be the price
of a house based on the area of the
house but as we go as the years go by
the the the the prices go up because of
different development which has taken
place in the in the area which probably
the model has not learned yet so the
model will fail so there are some main
reason but there could be a few more
yeah
um
and
last question I guess we have time for
from Paul is what happens if you fail an
assignment
was the process to go back and redo it
and you are given a chance to redo it
and we also try to understand what kind
of problem you face we try to clarify
those aspects and then you can redo it
but honestly telling you generally
doesn't happen because the way the
scores has been designed and the way
it's executed you will not have problem
in terms of clearing the examinations
and and tests that are there right in
most cases if you have an assessment
test that you have to clear you'll have
several options
um and then again several options for
projects so you'll be able
most instances to go back and take
another crack at it and
when you do of course you want to ask
your instructor and maybe your
classmates
for help in specific areas that you need
to do
help in
places that you
quite get the first time around
so let's ask a quick question uh would
you like us if you're interested in
enrolling for those of you who are would
you like us to reach out directly to you
and
let us know
just let you know we will be reaching
out to those of you who expressed
interest in the program
um but if you would like us to do that
quicker please answer yes here
I'll end the poll
about 50 50 of the people who answered
and so one last time I'm going to put
into the chat
information for the
email address and the program page
and
moment to copy that into the chat
there you go
so with that I am going to thank uh I'm
a team for his generosity with his time
and his expertise today uh it as always
a great pleasure hosting these with you
everything thank you so much
same here uh Stuart thank you so much
it's pleasure always pleasure sharing
the the webinar with you thank you so
much
and for those of you who want to use the
QR code on the screen it will take you
to the program web page
or you can of course email us at ask us
at simplylearn.net to reach our learning
Consultants that way
we hope that this has been uh helpful to
you in understanding the opportunities
in AIML and how to get started in the
field and we hope we can welcome you
into the Caltech and simply learn
learning community
so with that this concludes our webinar
for today
thank you all very much for being here
and taking time out of your day or your
evening to be with us